Chưa ba tháng 12, các bạn tình lận sân tổ chí khổ gị công cấp thông tin lên quan phụ ăn chết người xe ra trên đề bàn xả hữ lũ lũ tình lận sân.
Các bạn tình lận sân cho biết quá trình đều chắc đệnh nạn trên lần biến xuân đặt.
Xin năm 2018, chí cũng chú tại thôn hậu Trung 2, tên hơn tình gương eên và đối thưởng thực hiện hành bí xít người là đón phân sáng.
Xin năm 2018, chí trong sấu tám chú tại số 1,5 đường bởi khai phần tâm thành tình lận sân,
quyền là phó đội trường được quan lý tí chương xuống tình lận sân.
Các bạn đều chá ban đầu 3 đỉnh quan năm 2018,
người xáng quên đạt quan đến tàng mạng xả hội,
ngay hai lâm tháng 1,5 đáng 2021, có định thoại và thông nhất với đạt để đạt đến nưu làm việc của sáng,
tại đội quan lý tí chương xuống tình lận sân.
Tại đây xáng đã từ ghếp hành ví xít đạt, sau khi gèm xáng có nhiều hành ví tệ sóa dù vết,
phía tăng thi tệ, giằm buộc định chè dấu hành ví phạm tổ lối phó hối cửa quan chức năng.
Các bạn cứ tài liệu chính cứ sử dựa định từ thức thập được ngay hai tâm tháng 1,5 đáng 2021,
cơ quan cạnh sát điều tra công an tình lận sân đã xa quy định khởi tố phụ an hình sự giết người.
Ngay hai chính thống 1,5 đáng 2021, xa quy định khởi tố bị cán và lệnh bất bị cán để tạm sâm,
đối vết đoàn vàng sáng về tự giết người theo khoản một điều 1,5 đo thình sử năng ngay ngay 2021.
Hình công an tình lận sân đang tích tù phối hợp chỉ đau có đơn vị có lên quan,
gước lệnh đúng chăng truyết sát mở giọng điều tra sự liệu phụ an theo quy định.